Hi, I'm grant I'm back with visual politic. I'm bold, I'm British.
And unlike the previous host of this channel, I can't grow a beard.
So please guys stop asking
2020 is getting really very complicated for Donald Trump more than
120,000 coronavirus deaths and United States,
tens of millions of unemployed people and continuing street protests against
racism and police brutality.
[Inaudible].
And although it may have got lost in all the drama that has been happening
recently, just not forget that just a little while ago,
Trump was facing impeachment. Do you guys remember that?
If he doesn't don't worry.
I honestly didn't either a situation from which he emerged victorious,
but during which he was called all sorts of things and none of them were very
nice.
No, it was a flagrant assault on her electoral rights,
our national security and our fundamental values corrupting an election to keep
oneself in office is perhaps the most abusive and destructive
violation of one's oath of office that I can imagine.
Well, you could say a loader, but you couldn't really be any Cleaver.
And as a side note, if you think this accusation is already serious,
the most important thing is to pay attention to who made it,
because my visual politic nerds,
these words were not altered by an opposition leader,
but by a real life GOP Senator, and not just any Senator,
this is Mitt Romney,
one of the most important political figures in the political party,
but supports decisions and legislation made by the Trump administration. So,
and the face of impeachment Romney had to make a difficult decision choose
between being faithful to his own judgment or respecting party discipline
Watch carefully because Mitt Romney is not just any old Senator,
his political career and the Republican party is a very long one.
He was governor of the state of Massachusetts participated in the 2008
presidential primary and was the Republican nominee who faced Obama's reelection
in 2012 since last year.
He's also been a Republican Senator for Utah for a six year term,
a post that he could be in until January 20, 25.
No, my visual politic walks Trump overcame impeachment along with other reasons
because his fellow Republicans voted mostly against testimony that could have
proved key such as that of John Bolton,
national security advisor and the Trump administration itself.
We all remember John Bolton, right? He's got a book out now.
So you'll probably have seen him on literally every TV channel for this reason.
Many analysts believe that the GOP definitively surrendered to Trumpism Matt
day, however Romney's rebel vote left open a small crack and Donald Trump's
Republican armor,
a crank that has now been made worse during the recent events of 2020.
My visual politic nerds. One question starts to pop up.
Could there be an alternative to Trump?
Can the Senator for Utah be the spearhead of a new movement called on to defeat
Trumpism you'd best pay attention?
Because the last public appearance of Romney was him taking part in the
Washington anti-racism marches on the white tapes.
We need a voice against racism.
We need many voices against racism and against brutality.
We need to stand up and say that black lives.
Matter.
You don't want, if there's one thing,
Romney can bolster boat it's consistency and honesty.
As soon as he took the post of Senator,
before we even knew there was going to be an impeachment against the president
Romney was already predicting how he would manage his loyalty to Donald Trump,
listen up.
By and large followed the Republican playbook. So I'll be with him,
the places where I'm not with them from time to time will be matters of conduct
or communication that I think are highly defensive or misogynistic or
anti-immigrant in places like that.
I think it's important for my own personal integrity to stand up and say, no,
I disagree with that Mitt Romney, Republican Senator from Utah.
So possibly Romney's chance to be president of the United States is over,
but his influence could still be very important for the future of the Republican
party. That's why you hear on visual politics today.
We're going to review his trajectory,
his clashes with president Trump and his political position. Let's get moving.
King Midas.
Romney, and Donald Trump have one thing in common. They're both millionaires.
In fact, they're more than millionaires they're multi-millionaires,
but that's about as far as the similarities go. Well,
Trump is a guy prone to show an ostentatious Romney is the exact opposite and a
word scandal is not associated with him at all.
We are talking about discreet person with an exemplary family life on one who is
also heavily influenced by his religion.
Indeed,
this has all been much debated throughout his political career because Romney is
a Mormon and less than 2% of Americans are Mormons.
So many people wondered if religious prejudices would act against him.
Given his political journey is clear that this was not the case.
And that is because of Mormons magic underwear. Not really. Let me explain it.
Romney's father was the governor of Michigan and a member of Richard Nixon's
first government.
It seems clear that belonging to such an influential family was an important
advantage yet. The no Senator for UTA wasted no time.
After graduating from the law and business schools of the prestigious Harvard
university, he began a successful career as a businessman,
after a brief stint at the Boston consulting group,
Romney was seen by a rival consultant, Bain and company there.
He was chosen to lead the launch of Bain capital. Currently,
one of the leading venture capital funds in the entire world as an investor
Romney backed hugely successful firms,
such as staples and office supply chain and the world famous Domino's pizza.
These merits led to Romney eventually being named the CEO of being in company.
All of this allowed him to accumulate a personal fortune of more than
$200 million. But when and who that he started his political career,
this is the question that many of you may be wondering.
So you see in the U S a state where Mormons are the majority,
the States of Utah it's Capitol is salt Lake city.
So in the 1990s,
it became public that salt Lake city authorities had braved a lot of members of
the international Olympic committee to host the 2002 winter Olympics
bribery and a major sports and competition. Surely not. However, at the time,
that was a tremendous scandal, a scandal that rocked world sport,
the reputation of the Olympic games and left the organizing committee very badly
affected no one. And I mean,
absolutely no one wanted to sponsor those games and have their name linked to
corruption. Utah's prestige such as it is. Was it stake? So the question is,
what did they do next?
Then.
[Inaudible] disaster.
They named this new King maters who ran Bain and company as the head of the
organizing committee,
salt Lake city authorities did their best to organize those games and Romney
managed this.
He eliminated a $379 million deficit and ultimately made salt Lake
2020 a great success praised by the international Olympic committee.
No really that's right. Romney achieved,
close to a real miracle and Olympic games that weren't a financial disaster.
People of America, Utah, and salt Lake city.
You have given the world Superbowl games.
You have reassured us that people from all countries can live peacefully
together. Thank you.
Jock Broga president of the international Olympic committee during the closing
ceremony, the salt Lake city,
2002 Olympic games surplus from winter Olympics is
$56 million.
And so my visual politic Politico funds this success prompted Romney to jump
back into politics.
And I saved jumped back because he had previously chosen to be a Senator,
but he was pitted against the eternal Massachusetts Senator, Ted Kennedy,
none other than JFK's brother and for decades,
one of the great kingpins of the democratic party.
So he never really stood a chance
By now things have changed. And you know what,
when he was elected governor of Massachusetts,
he showed that his reputation as a King maters was well deserved.
He inherited a budget deficit of $3 billion.
And just two years later that had been transformed into a surplus of 700,000.
A million dollars is great.
Just achievement though, was this healthcare reform, uh,
reform negotiated with the democratic opposition that dominated the
Massachusetts legislature chamber with this reform Romney put in place a system
that forces all citizens to take out private health insurance,
to solve the state's most pressing social problem,
the lack of medical coverage of the uninsured, of course,
people who didn't have enough resources to take care of policy received help
from the state. It's a pretty meaningful model.
Let me think ensures that everyone has medical coverage stimulates competition
between insurers and the economies of scale are greater reducing policy costs
and improving service on the cost of the States is relatively low.
We saved that set of citizens who were making three times federal poverty or
more it's $54,000 a year in our state for a family of four.
You have to buy a policy that you can afford. And, um, uh,
and no more showing up at the hospital,
expecting someone else to pay your way for people earning less than three times,
federal poverty. We, we, the state will subsidize their purchase of a policy.
They choose the policy they want, we subsidize its purchase.
And that way we get everybody insured.
Mean it was quite the rising political star.
So he gave up seeking reelection as governor of Massachusetts and audit to run
in the Republican primaries. [inaudible] However,
he was late and joining the race for bushes successor, but the time he arrived,
it was already clear that John McCain would be the Republican's next choice,
as I'm sure we all remember Obama walked through that presidential election and
Romney immediately got to work on a new opportunity.
The American ideals of economic freedom and opportunity need to clear an
unapologetic defense.
And I intend to make it because I have lived it Mitt Romney.
In 2012, the stage was set. Romney was unrivaled and the Republican primaries,
and more importantly for us election,
but his campaign obtained huge amounts of funding. By the way,
among Romney's business supports, there were a few,
how should I best put this unstable elements?
It is tough. He is smart. He is sharp.
He is not going to allow bad things to continue to happen to this country that
we all love. So governor Romney go out and get him. You can do it.
Donald Trump in 2012,
Mitt Romney is a mixed up man who doesn't have a clue,
no wonder he lost Donald Trump in 2016.
By now, I think we're all pretty familiar with Donald Trump and has questionable
relationship with truth and coherence. The thing is Romney lost to Obama.
And as you knew, the GOP then fell into Trump's Taney hands. However,
my visual politic nerds,
if there was one person who was never a fan of the current tenant of the white
house is Mitt Romney. Check this out.
A Republican with principals [inaudible].
So to begin with Romney's profile was perfect for reaching the white house.
However, he had one small problem.
He lacked charisma with the American population to be fair to him.
Romney might be someone who'd be better as an actual president and as a
candidate,
something insurmountable when your rival is a guy as media-savvy photogenic and
as popular as Barack Obama.
Do you Mr. President on your anniversary,
I'm sure this was the most dramatic place you could imagine. Here.
Here with me, in addition,
democratic messaging succeeded in introducing Romney as a top executive,
without any scruples, someone capable of selling his own mother.
As long as it increased company profits.
Mitt Romney attacked 47% of Americans who pay no income tax,
including veterans elderly.
The disabled is not to worry about those fields.
Doesn't the president have to worry about everyone. I'm Barack Obama.
And I approve this.
What's interesting though,
was that something was changing and the soul of the Republican party just take a
loot at Clint Eastwood speech at the 2012 Republican convention.
It's maybe time for maybe a businessman
[inaudible].
Unfortunately for Republicans and particularly Clint Eastwood is that American's
preference Obama's messaging. And when they did go looking for a businessman,
there was no Romney. There was Donald.
Where are the shirts made Bangladesh? What is good?
We employ people in Bangladesh eyes where the ties beautiful ties.
They are great ties. The ties are made in where China eyes are made in China.
That Romney never wanted to see Trump in the white house.
This is what he had to say about the current president when they were both
fighting for the Republican nomination four years ago in 2016.
Donald Trump is a phony, a fraud.
His promises are as worthless as a degree from Trump university.
He's playing the members of the American public for suckers.
He gets a free ride to the white house and all we get is a lousy hat.
So now the question we have to ask is,
so does Romney criticize everything Trump does? And the truth is no.
He himself acknowledges that some of the Trump administration's economic
measures in the United States have worked much better than he expected.
He's also supported most of the president's appointments that he's made in his
administration. And in terms of foreign policy,
he's what some would call a Hawk.
And that he agrees with the heavy-handed policy towards China and Iran.
In other words,
he agrees with what we might describe as Donald Trump's Republican agenda books.
He hates Trump's methods and approaches that are at odds with the typical
Republican agenda. And the impeachment realm was the moment when Romney went,
you know what, this far and no further I've had enough. Yeah,
that was really Scottish. I'm sorry. When I get angry,
it comes out the president.
I asked a foreign government to investigate his political rival.
The president withheld vital military funds from that government depressant to
do so.
The president delayed funds for an American ally at war with Russian
invaders. President's purpose was personal and political accordingly.
The president is guilty of an appalling abuse of public trust.
Only two Republican senators voted with the democratic party to call for more
witnesses, including John Bolton, who had asked to testify, of course,
Romney was one of them, but it didn't matter.
The Republican majority laid down the petition and finally,
and the decisive vote Romney was the only Republican Senator to go against
Trump. However, November's elections are getting closer. If Trump is defeated,
the GOP will have to begin a new phase.
And the question is what could Romney contribute to them?
Romney 2024?
Um, these volts at impeachment corrects one of his biggest mistakes as a former
candidate,
which is that instead of going to the center of the political space in search of
more votes,
he chose and stent to plicate the tea party at the time of the primaries for the
16 elections. I'm sure you all remember the tea party.
And you know, up in Alaska, we have a smaller version of tea party up there.
We call it ice tea.
Partying as a GOP movement that I about a decade ago,
had a lot of influence within the organization in general,
as a movement that considers taxes to be theft that promotes a tough political
agenda and above all is a very nationalist movement, really nationalists.
In fact, in any case in 2012, Romney started from a moderate economic plan.
The gradually changed to bring about huge reforms to give you an idea.
One of the biggest electoral tricks was to put a huge tax cuts in place,
a much larger reduction in Trump mate, check it out.
Romney's tax reform meant a 20% drop for all taxpayers.
The maximum rate drops to 28% while with drum estate at 37%,
I stump has done Romney also pledged to make a huge reduction in taxing
corporate profits.
And that is not all Romney also promised a total tax exemption for capital
income,
the produced profits of under $200,000 and to offset all of these tax cuts
Romney pledged to reduce public spending to below 20% of USG.
So in other words.
Romney pledged to carry out a complete revolution that would have made the
United States. One of the most fiscally attractive countries in India.
Of course.
You know what the election campaigns promise everything.
But unlike Trump Romney as a strong advocate of budget balance,
and I don't know, probably if he were president,
he wouldn't have been able to carry out this change entirely. But in any case,
the course was clear. Mitt Romney is a true Republican,
even though some of his fellow politicians have approached him for things like
this, how Mitt Romney's healthcare experts helped design Obamacare.
So, yes, my visual politicals,
you surely know that Obama's health reform has been systematically criticized by
every Republican that has ever existed from the start.
Oh.
They find it very expensive. And Trump has tried to cancel it several times,
although he has not yet succeeded.
The fact is that the famous Obamacare was inspired by the Massachusetts
reformed. The met Romney implemented when he was governor. The idea makes sense,
forcing everyone to have private health insurance sets two things in motion.
One that with greater demand insurance companies have more room to lower prices
and compete with each other on a level playing field and to whoever can't afford
it can be given help so they can pay for the policies.
Then there's already the debates on how this health has to be and whether the
state has to take part or not in order to compete. In fact,
perhaps these are the biggest political differences. In any case,
we will talk about the health system in the United States very soon in another
video. And let's be honest probably until the end of time
In terms of foreign policy Romney is a strong advocate of trade with Mexico and
Canada.
So he probably wouldn't have gone with NAFTA and he would not have put tariffs
on a European union, either for Romney.
These countries in North America and Europe are strong allies of the United
States.
And so the heavy hand and all the protectionist measures must be limited only
to. So finally,
a lot of you may be wondering,
will Romney really find himself enough support to fight for the leadership of
post-Trump republicanism? Probably not,
but his collaborators such as Oren Cass have launched an American compass,
a new movement within the Republican party that aspires to lead the way for the
center, right in the coming years, make a note of names like Marco Rubio,
or Tom cotton as candidates for the upcoming Republican primaries.
But now as always, we leave the questions over to you.
Would you like to see Matt Romney as a candidate for the 2024 presidential
election? Do you think Trump will run again in 2020?
And how do I get some of that magic Mormon underwear?
Leave your answers in the comments below.
And if you find this video interesting,
please give us a Lake and don't forget to scrape it to visual politic.
If you haven't already, there's a little alarm button down there,
which you can click. If you want to get updates whenever our video is coming.
It's also,
don't forget to check out our friends on the reconsider media podcast,
all of the vocals in this episode that weren't mine were provided by them. Also,
I host a podcast called making Europe grants. Again,
I wonder where I got that slogan from.
If you're interested in a more comedic take on the news,
it's me and a bunch of my comedian friends talking about politics and world
events. You can find it on Spotify, iTunes, SoundCloud,
or whatever app you use to download your podcasts. Please check it out.
And as always, we hope you enjoyed the video.
You next time.
And if you want to learn more about politics and hear even more of my lovely
voice, you can join us at reconsider media. We have a
podcast@reconsideredmedia.com slash podcast. See you there.